الياس نذهب الى غزه من هناك معنا مراسل
الجزيره هشام
زقوط هشام ابدى معك فيما يتعلق بهذا
التبني الرسمي والبيان الرسمي من قبل حركه
حماس تتبنى فيه تنفيذ هذه العمليه
عبد القادر كانت حماس هذه المره الثانيه
التي تصدر فيها حماس بيانات بهذا الشكل
السريع ربما
احق الوصف هكذا بالامس القريب كانت هناك
تبني لعمليه حواره واليوم تتبنى حركه حماس
منفذ عمليه تل ابيب التي قالت بكل صراحه
انه احد اعضاء كتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس وهو المعتز بالله صلاح
الخواجه 23 عاما ووصفته بانه اسير محرر من
بلده نعلين غرب رام الله وقالت انه نفذ
عمليه اطلاق نار في شارع ديزنجوب بمدينه
تل ابيب
وقالت ان هذه العمليه جاءت ردا على جرائم
الاحتلال التي اعتقد انها تردع الشعب
الفلسطيني وتضعف ارادته بيان سريع من حركه
حماس تبنت فيه هذا الشهيد ووصفته بانه احد
اعضاء كتائب القسام باركه هذه العمليه
واكدت انها تاتي في سياق الرد الطبيعي على
جريمه الاغتيال جريمه اغتيال التي حدثت
اليوم في بلده جبع ومجزره جنين كذلك يوم
الثلاثاء وجرائم الاحتلال اليوميه التي
تصاعدت بحق سكان الضفه الغربيه وبتحريض
مباشر من حكومه الاحتلال كما قالت حركه
حماس في بيانها الذي صدر قبل قليل ايضا
حذرت حماس سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
التمادي في مواصفاته بجرائمها وعدوانها في
توغرها على دماء ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
وتدنيس المسجد الاقصى وتوعدت بالمزيد من
الضربات الموجعه في كل انحاء فلسطين
المحتلم المحتله طالما استمر العدوان
الاسرائيلي وتصاعدت الجرائم بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني واكدت كذلك ان الشعب الفلسطيني
متاهب للدفاع عن نفسه والانتقام لدماء
الشهداء مهما غلت التضحيات هذه هذا البيان
من حركه حماس وبيان امس من كتائب القسام
ربما يعتبر تطورا مهما في التنفيذ في
الاعلان عن عمليات الضفه الغربيه بعدما
استمرت حركه حماس وكتائب القسام لسنوات
وهي
تتجنب الاعلان بشكل رسمي وصريح عن
عملياتها في الضفه الغربيه واسرائيل كان
هناك ترحيب ربما يمكن وصفه بانه عام في من
كافه الفصائل الفلسطينيه كذلك كان هناك
ترحيب ومباركه من حركه الجهد الاسلامي
وقالت ان هذه العمليه هي ترسيخ لحق الشعب
الفلسطيني في مقاومه الاحتلال واكدت ان
على لسان طارق عز الدين الناطق باسم
الحركه ان هذه العمليه حطمت المنظومه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه ووجهت لها ضربه في
العمق لتؤكد قدره المقاومه
على الاستمرار في الوصول للاحتلال اينما
كان على لسان كما قلت الناطق باسم حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي طارق عز الدين كذلك كان
هناك بيان للجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
واكدت فيه ان عمليه تل ابيب هي جزء من
الرد الطبيعي والضروري على جرائم الاحتلال
الذي توغل على حد وصف البيان بالدم
الفلسطيني وقالت ان المقاومه باشكالها
كافه هي حق مشروع للشعب الفلسطيني ويجب
العمل على دعمه وتصعيد وازاله اي معيقات
تقف في طريقه وفي مقدمتها كما قالت
التنسيق الامني وما يرتبط به من صفقات
والتزامات مع العدو ايضا كان هناك عده
بيانات من عده فصائل فلسطينيه رحبت وباركت
بعمليه تل ابيب واكدت ان الشعب الفلسطيني
حسن خياراته على حسب مقاله الجبهه
الديمقراطيه لتحرير فلسطين واكدت ان الشعب
الفلسطيني حسن خياراته وان المقاومه وحدها
هي القادره على كنز الاحتلال كما قالت
وكنس المستوطنين والحاق الهزيمه بالمشروع
الاحتلالي الاسرائيلي وليس كما قالت مسار
العقبه وشرم الشيخ الامني وتفاهمته هشام
اعود ادقق معك في ما جاء من مفردات في
بيان حركه حماس
بالاشاره الى لماذا نفذت هذه العمليه ثم
هناك اشاره لافته تتوعد بمزيد من العمليات
الموجعه وهنا اضع خط تحت كلمه موجعه عمليه
هذه الليله كما قال الياس قبل قليل هي في
قلب قلب تل ابيب في شارع ديزينغو وبالتالي
ايضا لغه ولهجه تصعيديه من حماس مزيد من
العمليات الموجعه
بالفعل عبد القادر ربما يمكن القول ان
حماس خلال اليوم وامس كانت بياناتها واضحه
صريحه بانها تتبنى عمليات في الضفه
الغربيه في اسرائيل في داخل وقلب اسرائيل
وتحذر وتتوعب بمزيد من هذه العمليات وهذا
تطور جديد وملحوظ في خطاب حركه حماس الذي
امتنع على مدار سنوات من التلويح او
التوضيح ان هذه العمليات هي مسؤوله عنها
حركه حماس وتتبناها بشكل صريح هذا ربما
ينقل المواجهه وينقل العمليات في الضفه
الغربيه واسرائيل الى مرحله اخرى حتى وان
كانت هذه العمليات فرديه فانها تشجع
المزيد من الفلسطينيين لتنفيذ هذه
العمليات كما تقول حماس وجميع الفصائل فان
فان المقاومه في كل الاعراف هي حقل الشعوب
التي تناضل من اجل الحريه والاستقلال
وفكره المقاومه هي اصلا
فكره مرتبطه بوجود الاحتلال الذي يمارس
الاعتداءات والانتهاكات بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني واسرائيل ترتكب الجرائم بحق
الشعب الفلسطيني هذه العمليه وتوعد حماس
بمزيد من العمليات يؤكد ان حماس نقلت ساحه
المواجهه الى الضفه الغربيه وان ربما يمكن
القول بحسب الكثير من المحللين حماس تتجنب
الاشتباك مع الاحتلال من قطاع غزه وترى ان
ساحه المواجهه الاساسيه يجب ان تكون في
الضفه الغربيه وان الضفه الغربيه تدافع عن
نفسها وتدافع عن الحق الفلسطيني وتدافع عن
جرائم ضد جرائم الاحتلال والانتهاكات
المستمره والمتواصله بحق الفلسطينيين لا
يكاد يخلو يوم من الجريمه اسرائيليه جديده
بحق فلسطينيين عمليات اغتيال عمليات
اجتياح عمليات توغل وبالامس كانت هناك
عمليات توغل في داخل قطاع غزه وانفجرت
عبوه ناسفه في احدى الدبابات وهذا يؤكد ان
جميع الاراضي الفلسطينيه هي جاهزه ومستعده
كما تقول الفصائل الفلسطينيه لرد على
انتهاكات الاحتلال المتواصله كما تقول
الفصائل ان اسرائيل ترتكب يوميا الجرائم
بحق الشعب الفلسطيني هناك اعتقالات وادمات
ميدانيه على الحواجز وهناك فشل في توفير
افق سياسي في ظل كل هذه الجرائم وبالتالي
المقاومه هي وحدها وحدها هي الوسيله
الوحيده بحسب هذه الفصائل للرد على هذه
العدوان وهذه الانتهاكات المتواصله